>> Greg: WHILE DISNEY
POINTS FINGERS -- INGRAM
RECEIVED RACIST MESSAGES
ONLINE SINCE THE SHOW
PREMIERED LAST WEEK.
YIKES, BEAM ME UP, SCOTTIE.
SHE SHARED SOME ON INSTAGRAM
WHICH INCLUDED USE OF THE
N-WORD AND THREATS LIKE
"YOUR DAYS ARE NUMBERED."
SHOCKING.
WHO KNEW HUNTER BIDEN WAS
ONLINE?
SOON AFTER THE OFFICIAL
"STAR WARS" ACCOUNT TWEETED,
PROUD TO WELCOME MOSES
INGRAM TO "STAR WARS" FAMILY
AND EXCITED FOR THE STORY TO
UNFOLD.
IF ANYONE INTENDS TO MAKE
HER FEEL UNWELCOME, WE HAVE
ONLY ONE THING TO SAY, WE
RESIST.
LATER, THEY ADDED THERE ARE
MORE THAN 20 MILLION SPECIES
IN THE "STAR WARS" GALAXY,
DON'T CHOOSE TO BE A RACIST.
SENDING RACIST DRIBBLE IS
RACIST.
HAVE WE LEARNED NOTHING FROM
WHEN CAPTAIN KIRK HITS
LIEUTENANT UHORAH?
WHAT FANS TOOK ISSUE WITH IS
"STAR WARS" INSINUATING THE
ASHES OF A FEW [BLEEP]
PEOPLE REPRESENT THEM AS A
WHOLE WHEN THEY REMINDED
"STAR WARS" OF THEIR
PREVIOUS COWARD HE'S WHEN IT
-- COWARDICE WHEN IT CAME TO
CHINA.
IN 2019 WHEN THE FORCE
AWAKENS WAS RELEASED, THE
POSTER FEATURED THE BLACK
ACTOR BUT THE CHINESE
VERSION MINIMIZED HIS
PRESENCE.
THERE'S ONE EVIL EMPIRE
"STAR WARS" WON'T RESIST.
MEANWHILE OTHER FANS POINTED
OUT "STAR WARS" CONTENT
FEATURES MANY BLACK ACTORS
LIKE BILLY D. WILLIAMS OR
THE FACT JAMES EARL JONES
PLAYED DARTH VADER'S VOICE
FOR YEARS LONG BEFORE I WAS
BORN.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT A CLIP
FROM THE FIRST EPISODE.
>> OBI-WAN, YOU SHALL MEET
YOUR ULTIMATE DEMISE.
>> WAIT.
WAIT.
WHO IS THAT OTHER GUY WITH
YOU?
>> OH.
OH.
THAT'S JUST STEVE.
STEVE AND I ARE ROOMMATES.
>> JUST YOUR ROOMMATES?
>> WELL, HE'S MY FRIEND.
WE PRACTICE SOME FORCE ON
EACH OTHER.
>> NO.
NO.
IT'S COOL.
I BROUGHT A FRIEND, TOO.
THIS IS MY BRUNCH CREW.
>> CAN I COME TO BRUNCH WITH
YOU?
>> AS LONG AS YOU KEEP THAT
MASK ON.
>> STEVE.
DON'T EMBARRASS ME IN FRONT
OF YOUR BRUNCH FRIENDS.
BRUNCHY, BRUNCHY, BRUNCHY.
WAHOO.
>> KAT YOU WERE ADAMANT
ABOUT DOING THIS STORY.
YOU'RE CONSIDERED ONE OF THE
NATION'S TOP EXPERTS IN
"STAR WARS."
>> IN BEING THREATENED BY
"STAR WARS" FANS, YES?
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, ISN'T
IT ONE OF THOSE EASY WAYS TO
GET ATTENTION BY
HIGHLIGHTING -- OUT OF
BILLIONS OF FANS, YOU, LIKE,
-- LIKE, YOU ACTUALLY
PROJECT THE STUFF?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> SUCH A WEIRD THING TO DO
TO BE LIKE, HERE IS OUR NEW
CHARACTER.
IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T NOTICED,
SHE IS BLACK, SO DIDN'T BE
RACIST.
LIKE, YOU TAKE RACE OUT OF
IT AND JUST IMAGINE DOING
THAT WITH ANYTHING, YOU CAN
SEE HOW NUTS IT IS.
IF YOU POSTED, LIKE, YOU GET
MARRIED.
YOU'RE LIKE, HERE I AM WITH
MY NEW HUSBAND.
IF YOU THINK HE'S A SCHLOP
AND I CAN DO BETTER, DON'T
SAY THAT.
I WON'T LIKE IT.
LIKE, YOU'RE PUTTING THAT
OUT THERE.
IT'S SUCH A WEIRD, WEIRD
MOVE.
>> Greg: I KNOW.
YOU KNOW, TYRUS, YOU CAN GO
ON TWITTER AND FIND 100
WEIRDOES TO VALIDATE ANY
KIND OF TOXIC BELIEF, BUT
MEANWHILE, IT'S THAT
SELF-SELECTION THING.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE SAY
NOTHING, BUT THAT'S BORING.
>> I MEAN, I CAN'T -- I
DON'T DIG TOO MUCH OF MY
STUFF BUT I WILL LITERALLY
GET AT LEAST FIVE OR SIX
RACIST TWEETS AT LEAST A
WEEK.
IT'S ALWAYS THE SAME THING.
IF I COME ACROSS IT, BLOCK.
MOVE ON.
I DON'T HAVE TIME, BUT THEY
NEVER COME TO MY HOUSE AND
DO IT.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WAS HERE --
AND THIS IS WHERE THE WOKE
-- THEY PICK THEIR BATTLES.
THE FANS WERE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE BOX BEING CHECKED.
THAT THE ACTUAL CHARACTER
WAS, IN FACT, SOMETHING
ELSE, AND THEY JUST FILLED
THE BOX AND THAT'S WHAT
DISNEY DOES.
THEY FILL THE BOX AND THEN
THEY COMPLAINED ABOUT IT.
SO -- AND THEN THEY TOOK THE
WORST OF 'EM, THEY FOUND THE
COMPLETE MORONS WHO MAKE
RACIST ARGUMENTS BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T FORMULATE THEIR
OWN THOUGHTS AND THAT'S THE
ONE THEY FOCUSED ON TO GET
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION SO NO
ONE WILL CRITICIZE, A, BAD
ACTING OR, B, IT DOESN'T FIT
BECAUSE THAT'S HOW THE WOKE
DO -- THAT'S HOW THEY DO
THEIR THING.
LOOK, THE SISTER SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO EVER HEAR SOMEONE
CALLING HER AN N-WORD BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WHY ARE YOU
GIVING IT AIR?
I REFUSE TO GIVE ANYONE ANY
AIR THAT TALKS ANY TRASH
ABOUT ME, BECAUSE THAT'S ALL
THEY'RE DOING IT FOR.
ONCE THEY GET AIR, THEN THEY
SIT IN THEIR LITTLE CHAT
GROUP AND SAY, SEE?
I CAN'T BELIEVE HE SAID
THAT.
HOW'D YOU BLOCK ME?
BLOCKED AGAIN.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
YOU DON'T GIVE IT AIR, IT'S
NOT AN ISSUE.
>> Greg: SHANNON, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT THE CHINA
ASPECT OF THIS?
OK.
YOU GUYS CAN BE RACIST
BECAUSE WE NEED YOUR MONEY.
>> RIGHT AND THEY CHANGE
THING -- THEY TAKE THINGS
OUT OF MOVIES.
THEY TOOK SOMETHING OUT OF
HARRY POTTER.
THE STUDIO DID THAT.
>> Greg: THEY REMOVED ME
FROM THE LAST JAMES BOND
MOVIE.
>> IT'S SURPRISINGLY --
>> YOU WERE REMOVED FROM THE
SET.
>> SURPRISINGLY --
>> THAT'S DIFFERENT.
>> IT ALSO SAYS YOU WERE
REMOVED FROM THE U.S.
EDITION.
>> Greg: YES, I WAS.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO BE IN SO
MUCH TROUBLE.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU AFTER
THIS SEGMENT, BECAUSE YOU
MISSED -- MIXED "STAR WARS"
AND "STAR TREK" AND MARVEL.
THE FANS OF THESE THINGS ARE
NOT HAPPY WHEN THAT GETS
INTERMIXED.
I'M WORRIED FOR YOUR SAFETY.
>> YOU WOULD BE A GOOD
BONDSMAN.
>> I THINK WHAT THEY ALL
HAVE IN COMMON I WILL NEVER
WATCH ANY OF THEM.
.>> I'M A TRUE NE RD.
THIS IS NOT MY AREA OF NERD
EXPERTISE.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU NERD
ON?
>> I'LL ALWAYS READ BOOKS.
>> Greg: BLACK CHARACTERS
HAVE BEEN IN "STAR WARS" FOR
45 YEARS.
IN ORDER TO GET ANGRY AND
SAY PEOPLE -- YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME PEOPLE ARE MORE
RACIST NOW THAN THEY WERE
THEN.
THAT'S -- CATEGORICALLY,
THAT CAN'T BE TRUE, RIGHT?
>> WELL, NOT -- IF YOU ASK
THEM, THEY'LL TELL YOU THE
OPPOSITE.
IT'S IRONIC TO ME THAT WE
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT RACISM
JUST TO INJECT IT BACK INTO
THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE OR
THE MEDIA LANDSCAPE.
WHEN I WAS IN GOVERNMENT, I
GOT DEATH THREATS.
I GOT CALLED THE WORST
THINGS.
I GOT STUFF SENT TO MY
HOUSE.
I DIDN'T GIVE IT AIR TIME.
I JUST SAID HERE YOU GO.
HERE IS THE SECURITY CHECK.
MOVING ON I GOT E-MAILS ALL
THE TIME.
THEY MONOPOLIZED THE
INDUSTRY TO SAY THAT CAN'T
HAPPEN TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
CONSERVATIVE OR REPUBLICAN
OR WORK FOR TRUMP.
WE NEVER TALKED ABOUT IT.
WE JUST DID THE JOB AND KEPT
PUNCHING ON AND MOVING ON.
NOW, THEY'RE LOSING ON
EVERYTHING FROM AMAZON TO
DISNEY TO TWITTER TO WHAT
HAVE YOU.
NOW THEY'RE LIKE, OK, LET'S
TAKE THE "STAR WARS" EMPIRE
AND MAKE EVERYONE RACIST
AGAIN.
>> Greg: ANYONE EVER
SHOWED UP AT YOUR HOUSE?
>> YES, YOU.
>> Greg: I WANTED TO SEE
IF YOU REMEMBERED.
JUST READ THE CARD.
>> UM, THE SECRET SERVICE
HAS IT.
>> Greg: UM.
>> HE DID VIOLATE --
>> Greg: THERE WERE
POLAROIDS IN THE CARD.
TOOK ME HOURS TO GET THA